just to amuse you I'll tell you a story
that has never been told nothing that's
top secret anymore but because it was so
interesting during the Vietnam War I had
been doing a lot of work on chemical
communication particularly in ants you
know in the end the study advances we we
claim credit those of us who study the
biology events for having really
advanced the subject of pheromone study
and chemical communication which is
important and among animals which is
important because human beings are one
of the very few audio-visual creatures
on earth most of the rest of life is
chemical as pheromone how to communicate
so I was working on that in the ants and
helping to dis decode we were we were
decoding the ant pheromone language well
about that time the army decided that it
wasn't literally it wanted to literally
sniff out the enemy in Vietnam because
there was so much danger you know and
these Rascals coming out of their their
tunnels suddenly or or advancing on you
slowly through the jungle and they
didn't know how to pick them up figure
out when an attack was coming so there
was actually and I had only a marginal
amount of this I hardly any at all but
but I kept on I knew about it was to
analyze the odor of a human being as we
had been analyzing the odors and the
chemicals released by ants to
communicate and to then have what was
what's called a sniffer scope which
would be set up and so that downwind you
would turn the red light on when human
odor came into it and there were more
than in the course of this research
which is valuable basic research behind
it they they actually chemically
identified
than 100 elements of the human odor I
never heard that the sniffer scope was
ever used
you